c'est cette polémique est totalement est
totalement ridicule juste pour réagir
sur sur le sur ce que vient de dire
monsieur le maire de cette petite
commune moi je suis candidat à la
présidentielle également on a on est en
train de rechercher les parrainages on a
déjà dépassé les 5 ans du premier
parrainage durant un mois je vous invite
dans mario rossi jalons pour faire un
meeting j'invite tout le monde donc
c'est gentil mais enfin moi je comprends
pas comment 7,7 cette sortie de zemmour
et le discours de zemmour parle à vous
en tant que maire d'une petite commune
je dis pas que tous les tous les maires
de france sont un bloc monolithique et
tous ont la même vision et la même
lecture mais nous en tout cas les mères
qu'on va visiter passe vous doutez bien
c'est les maires des petites de chercher
votre 500 signatures oui actuellement là
aujourd'hui avait même une équipe de la
chaîne comment j'en avais déjà ouais on
a dépassé déjà les 50 premières
signatures au mois d'août on a commencé
son visage
on va chercher à les avoir honte je suis
candidat sérieusement c'est à dire que
c'est pas une candidature folkloriques
ou quoi que ce soit on espère et
j'espère être là est être candidate sur
la ligne de départ mais fort pour
revenir sur 7 sur ce fait qu'un un maire
d'une petite ville paraît nemo c'est
incompréhensible pour moi un bon choix
parce que la totalité des maires qu'on
peut rencontrer même ceux qui souhaitent
pas parrainer anas quasiment fait ils
ont tous les mêmes problématiques la
question des transports publics on vient
dans toutes les villes il n'y a pas une
seule ville une petite commune il n'y a
pas écrit non à la fermeture de la salle
de classe ramenez-nous des médecins cgtr
et c c'est à dire que l'après la
préoccupation première de l'ensemble de
ses moeurs et les maires gilet jaune
c'est ce qu'ils ont vu la colère émerger
de cette france périurbaines ils l'ont
vu en fait cette colère ils l'ont vu en
fait arrivé parce que eux-mêmes ont vu
le bureau de poste fermés la boulangerie
l'école les classes etc et nous quand on
vient parler avec eux lorsqu'ils
entendent un cheminot ouvriers qui sait
c'est quoi le service public qui vient
avec des propositions concrètes en fait
pour en finir avec ce système là ça leur
parle mais venir en fait qu'est-ce que
ça change au moindre aux moindres à la
moindre personne de votre commune en
fait que demain on appelle un nas kazim
jean-pierre quasi qu'est-ce que ça est
ce que j'ai déjà j'ai une tête à
m'appeler jean-pierre sérieuse très
sincèrement
ça va changer quoi exactement ça change
strictement rien sur la question sur la
question des prénoms c'est terrible
parce que s'il
n'y a pas une tête à s'appeler jean
pierre c'est quoi cette auto racisme là
où vous êtes et vous savez avant et
jean-pierre personnes auraient rigolé je
suis désolé mais pour moi moi mon prénom
et g1 j'avais un prénom d'origine par
pour m'assimiler effectivement j'ai
changé un dire j'ai changé mon prénom
gorge il te ment rien dire ouais le
meeddat attendez attendez moi j'en ai
ras le bol si vous voulez toujours de ce
deux poids deux mesures parce que les
mêmes qui aujourd'hui brocarde les gens
qui changent de près nous avons
carrément accro qui brocarde la
proposition d'eric zemmour sont les
premiers à applaudir lorsque jean
lorsque jean baptiste devient mohamed
après une conversion à l'islam cassius
clay devenu mohamed ali qui continue à
l'appeler cassius clay qui a dit c'est
honteux il a changé de prénom personnes
face à moi mais c'est le jeu ça peut
passer mais il ya deux poids deux
mesures nécessaires hélas combien de
fois ces débats vous jeudi nous avons je
vous avais je n'ai pas de noms mais nous
allons être nombreux et nous allons vers
de
matériel je peux finir mon propre
plaisir nous sommes la france d'accord
on a une communauté nationale comme dans
n'importe quel pays du monde qui a une
identité nationale dans le mot identité
nationale il y a identique c'est-à-dire
que quand vous portez la nationalité
française je parle pas des immigrés qui
sont des résidents
ça c'est une autre une autre question
mais quand vous portez la nationalité
française il faut faire ce que vous
pouvez pour ressembler au peuple et à la
nation dont vous portez à l'aller des
messages d'amour et ça c'est votre
histoire et je
finissais là pour l'épauler ce gardien
vous pouvez effectivement choisir de
rester mohamed abdoullah etc y'a pas de
soucis mais ne venez pas ensuite vous
plaindre de discrimination parce que el
cid a bien sûr donc vous soit vous
vous avez déjà d'une part c'est à dire
par les jambes vous appelez d'une
discrimination un apport dans l'âtre
histoire d'un intense de pips sait on
aborde une théorie du monde dans
n'importe quel pays du monde doivent
visionner dans la forme de quel pays du
monde je l'aurais cibc un pays du monde
les gens les gens font le meilleur
accueil à ce qui ressemble le plus à des
sessions oui cette finale
enfin un moment donné il faut dire la
vérité sur ce qui est en train de
raconter monsieur messia est ce que
racontent ces mots on est en train de
faire du révisionnisme en fait de
l'histoire de france de toujours croire
qu'en fait la france et vercingétorix
c'est que ça que la france en fait c'est
pas la colonisation c'est pas le
massacre d'algériens sétif et c'est que
c'est le vin sacré
réalisme ça me suis dit ici à moi mon
père on est venu le chercher au maroc on
lui a demandé de venir travailler
d'accord vous avez mon père je vous
écris
le capitalisme français ça le dérangeait
pas dans les usines de simca de renault
de 6,3 d'ores et déjà pour le vrai jo et
salles de prière à la force d'y remédier
en
venez travailler là on a besoin de voir
à l'arrière en place des doigts de rabat
et nous savons que les gens et patrice
est dans les hôtels arrêtez d'inventer
nom de la france de plus votre histoire
c'est fort de la france n'a pas tremblé
un carrousel et colonial vous y intégrer
fonde avec la fermer saab est vraiment
beaucoup on est en train de dériver vers
un autre débat qui hystérise absolument
tout c'est tout ce que je déteste moi
j'ai trouvé très intéressant votre pompe
au sol un petit maire qui n'a aucune
importance
et ben oui mais sur les prés de normes
alors moi je suis je suis content de ce
taux que c'est un débat qui parasitent
complètement livré débat dans quoi je
suis contre ce débat mais en revanche je
trouve intéressant ce que vous avez dit
et je trouve intéressant ce que je
voulais faire une deuxième de la poule
mais oui et monsieur cette dérive vers
un débat politique complète à la
division qui n'a pas levé je vous avoue
coûté une anecdote en fait moi j'ai vécu
à l'étranger le racisme je les ai connus
à l'étranger est ce que précisément en
italie au don sud de l'italie les
prénoms français c'est pas génial c'est
pas du racisme ça monsieur donne à mes
yeux ça c'est pas du racisme et des
silhouettes n'y a pas que ça pâques
c'est uniquement s'il est donc ce que je
veux dire c'est que en fait tout l'enjeu
c'est de réussir à permettre de dépasser
la question des prénoms dont on se fout
royalement pour aussi réussir à enrichir
à s'enrichir mutuellement une culture
réciproque c'est tout en revenant je le
dis différemment entre siamois non mm
mais oui mais il ya un problème et votre
raisonnement non c'est un symbole le
président arias c'est un prénom vous
acceptez pas rien maria ça marche ça
marche sortie qu'une marine ça marche
steven guen et c'est énormément ya une
bonne et moi
ça vient des pays je sais bien
voir non mais attendez dans l'île le
pouf m série 2 reste un mot vous êtes
cas les rires vous savez ce cas de perte
stosur sur ce que dit zemmour il cite
notamment les loi de 1803 enfin faut
savoir que c'est des décrets de la honte
ça s'appelait comme ça c'était des lois
qui était antisémite en fait on a
récemment fait écouter bas alors
je prends ça très bien être le mouton
crt de loi qui ont été des lois
antisémites leur manière dont
on allait devenir simple assemblage en
suède